with minnesota senator amy klobuchar who
was in the senate chamber yesterday as
that evidence was presented she was also
among those who were rushed to safety on
january 6.
she joins us now senator klobuchar i'm
so glad to see you listen
thanks gail listen we all knew that it
was a dangerous situation
we were watching it in real time back
january 6 but i think yesterday
we got to see how dangerous it was i'm
so haunted by the police officers
where you can hear the fear and the
urgency in their voice
as they were trying to protect
themselves and protect you all
what did you learn yesterday that maybe
you didn't know
well i from the beginning had always
thought about those police officers
because bottom line
a lot of us weren't as scared as maybe
we should have been
but we weren't scared because the police
officers were there and that moment
where the officer is
shrieking in pain literally putting his
body
uh and got wedged in a door between
this angry mob and all of us to protect
us
is what you don't forget or the
african-american officer
after being called the n-word 15 times
being
impaled with polls with the american
flag saying to his friend
is this america um those are things i
don't forget so i think
people are finally realized these cops
over 100 of them were injured this was
very very dangerous for them and they
were the front line victims
senator there have been reports that
that some of your republican colleagues
were quite troubled
by the video they've seen uh in the last
couple of days
is do you get any sense that there is
any movement on the republican side
in terms of this impeachment vote well
we know there was one senator
that surprisingly uh changed and voted
with us when it came to allowing
the case to proceed to a trial center
cassidy of louisiana
and we have to think of it this way that
initial vote to allow it to go forward
and say it's constitutional to have the
trial
that was one vote but after that to me
there's a reset you basically say okay
this is the law it gets to go forward
now you got to make a decision on the
facts so you don't know where they are
right now if some of them will
will decide uh to vote to impeach the
president
i don't know how you get away from the
facts not only what he did
but what he didn't do when he didn't
call in the national guard and his vice
president had to do it when his vice
president had was in peril
or he didn't tell his very firmly tell
his
people to get out of the capitol to
leave to stop
with his family members telling him to
do it with governor christie telling him
to do it
you just can't get away from those
strong facts yeah what he didn't say was
just as important as what he didn't do
was just as important as what people
thought
that he did do i'm wondering what was
the reaction as you all were watching it
together as a group because there are
reports that senator hawley for instance
was kicked up on was you know kicking
back on the top level
either reading a paper or reading a
magazine a is that possibly true
and lindsey graham tweets that the the
presentation was offensive and absurd
how do we get together when there seems
to be so much
or maybe indifference as to what people
saw yesterday
is that true about senator hawley is
that true i wouldn't have been able to
see him because he'd be above me no the
senators were allowed to go
up there during the trial because of
covid to space out
most people just stayed in their chairs
so i didn't see him do that
but i i don't understand why anyone
could say this was
offensive it was just the facts yeah the
facts are offensive the facts are
horrific they're hard to watch
but it is what happened and so i do
think though you see
other republicans that are very moved
horrified
looking down looking upset so who knows
uh what they will do and where they're
conscious will guide us but this is a
moment
of patriotism you've got to do what's
right for the country
senator the capitol has always been a
remarkably accessible
federal building a house for the people
in effect
you're on the rules committee do you see
that having to change
after this well as a chair of the rules
committee we are going to have hearings
um in the next month on
exactly that what happened what went
wrong
what kind of intelligence did they have
and what happened with the perimeter you
heard many times the cries
you know they breached the line we've
lost the line we've lost the line that
was one of the
scariest thing so yes i think that we'll
have to look at where that perimeter is
what kind of presence of law enforcement
and even potentially
national guard not in the numbers we
have now which is needed because of the
heightened risk
but what we do around the capitol and of
course that should be something it's
you just can't go back to things like
they were you can still have
accessibility for the public you can
still have tours those things can happen
but to protect not just us but to
protect
the officers the people we're going to
have to look at some changes
all right senator klobuchar thank you so
much for being with us thank you anthony
thank you
thank you gail